high-level face-to-face talks between
u.s and chinese diplomats are
highlighting
sharp differences between the sides
china has issued a long list of demands
and complaints
accusing the u.s of trying to contain
and suppress
china's development the u.s has brought
up concerns about human rights and other
issues
it is urging cooperation on matters
including climate change
iran and north korea president biden
said today the u.s combat
combat mission in iraq is ending but he
still intends on keeping a small force
in that country to train and advise
iraqi troops
the president met today with iraq's
prime minister national security
correspondent jennifer griffin shows us
tonight
a week after a suspected isis suicide
bomber attacked a baghdad market
killing 35 people and as iranian-backed
shia militias keep firing rockets at u.s
troops in the american embassy
president biden announced america's
combat operations in iraq are coming to
an end
our role in iraq is just
to be available to continue to train to
assist
to help and to deal with isis as
it arrives but we are not going to be by
then here in a combat mission
the announcement came at the request of
iraq's prime minister who visited the
white house today
i'd like to thank the american people on
behalf of
all iraq's people but unlike in
afghanistan president biden plans to
keep the current number of 2500 u.s
troops on the ground to train advise and
assist their iraqi partners
to make sure isis does not return iran
and its proxy forces are calling for a
full american withdrawal
the iraqi prime minister is facing
important elections in october and
tremendous pressure from iranian
sympathetic members of parliament
who want u.s troops out calls which
became louder in the wake of the u.s
drone strike that killed iran's top
general qasim sulaimani last year
after he landed at the baghdad airport
the state department basically halted
all combat operations in april
today's announcement is reminiscent of
2011
when then vice president biden led the
obama administration's effort to end the
war in iraq
we will in fact as i said at the outset
draw down our military forces by the end
of december
three years later the u.s military had
to return to fight isis which was
closing in on baghdad
u.s officials tell us none of the 2500
u.s troops
currently in iraq are being sent back
home brett
jenner i just talked about china there's
new reporting now that the french
warned the u.s government about china's
secretive behavior at the wuhan
institute of virology back in 2015.
that's the place
where it may have started the
coronavirus by accident or otherwise
that's right brett we have long known
that the french helped build the wuhan
lab a deal with china that dates back
to 2004 and that the french were
responsible for managing its safety
protocols
until they were suddenly kicked out of
the lab by the chinese government back
in 2017.
two years before that according to david
asher the state department's former lead
investigator
into the coveted origin french
intelligence
allegedly warned the u.s government that
it had concerns about chinese actions at
the laboratory
jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thank you hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else